[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Why
would MIT students
bring their toenail
clippings to class?
And how do 100 people learn how
to fly airplanes in three days?
Could a film
experience really be
more important than
learning quantum physics?
This is Chalk Radio, a podcast
about inspired teaching at MIT.
We have conversations with
some of the professors
that make some of the
most interesting courses
on campus come to life.
The conversations we
have with our guests
are candid, funny,
serious, and personal.
They're the kind
of conversations
you'd have if you bumped
into your favorite professor
in the Infinite Corridor and
walked with them across campus.
And that's why we're doing this.
We want you to feel like
you're right here with us
walking underneath the Dome,
experiencing the buzz that
happens when people who love
science, learning, and teaching
all come together to
think, talk, and dream.
I hope you listen
to Chalk Radio.
It's really the closest
thing to being here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]